le tri c'est occupe 100 % de 100% de ma
vie je respire je vive pour le triathlon
quoi tout est fait tout m'aviez orienté
vers le triathlon pour le triathlon
thomas ont drainé pas le génie de son
sport et il le sait mais ce bourreau de
travail vient de remporter les
championnats du monde espoirs de
duathlon
à 22 ans ce licencié du triathlon club
de saint quentin en yvelines arrive à
maturité
pourtant son apprentissage du haut
niveau a été difficile intégré au pôle
espoir français en 2005
le natif de marseille est écarté de la
structure pour manque de résultats je
faisais une saison correcte en première
année espoirs j'avais j'avais fait 5e à
aux championnats de france espoirs pour
une première année c'était honnête en
plus sur une course difficile j'avais
réussi à faire 16e sur une coupe
d'europe élite
j'avais fait des résultats corrects mais
la fédé attendait de moi des résultats
excellents
parce que ça faisait cinq ans j'étais
sur une structure donc qu'il voulait il
voulait déjà un champion quoi ai-je été
page était pas un champion ce champion
thomas andré a appris à le devenir
malade juste avant les championnats du
monde à nancy il bat pourtant ce jour là
son record sur la course à pied son
point fort
également champion du monde
universitaire cette saison et vice
champion de france espoirs l'athlète de
saint quentin en yvelines veut continuer
de progresser
j'ai des grosses ambitions pour l'année
prochaine ça veut dire sur triathlon et
duathlon j'ai envie de faire des places
des belles places voire même gagné des
titres sur sur des les championnats
d'europe voire même les championnats du
monde voilà je vais me rapprocher du top
aux côtés de frédéric belaubre triple
champion d'europe de triathlon
thomas andré continue de repousser ses
limites pour faire retentir à nouveau la
marseillaise sur un podium international